foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video we will be looking at all the new
photos and videos released by HBO with
only a day away from HBO airing its
fifth episode of House of the Dragon
they've released many new official
photos and videos showcasing what will
happen in the following episodes in the
first season now I don't want to bury
the lead therefore the first thing I
want to do is look at the new scene that
was shown last night during Matt's
interview on the Jimmy Fallon Late Night
show in this new scene we get to see
what Damon says to renera during her
wedding now before we actually get
started there is something I should
mention I want to discuss the sponsor of
this video Atlas VPN as I'm sure most of
you already know all of us are at risk
of having our identity stolen on a daily
basis as more and more of our
information and data goes on to the
internet what some of you might not know
is that one of the best ways of stopping
this from happening is by the use of a
VPN service I actually use mine every
day in fact I won't turn on any of my
devices unless I'm already connected
well this month I've joined forces with
Atlas VPN to bring you the most
affordable deal on online protection for
as little as 1.99 each month they also
give you a 30-day money-back guarantee
now other than guarding your online
identity Atlas VPN also blocks malware
and malicious links they will make sure
your Google searches are private and
they'll give you access to online
shopping deals and even notify you
whenever someone is trying to steal your
identity one of my favorite things about
Atlas VPN is it also gives you access to
other regions content on the different
streaming services like Netflix for
example if something is only available
in the UK all you have to do is switch
your IP address to gain access to it in
the US right now Atlas VPN is running a
massive discount to where you can
actually get a three-year subscription
for only 1.99 each month and don't
forget that also has a 30-day money-back
guarantee all of you can jump on that
deal right now before time Runs Out by
going to the link in my description I
recommend grabbing that deal now once
again again I would like to thank
atlasvpn for sponsoring the video now
let's have a look at the new scene
as you can see Damon still has his eyes
set on runera although he does think
Leonor is a good man he knows renera
will not enjoy her marriage with him one
of the reasons why he thinks renero
won't enjoy her marriage with him is
because Lenor is not really interested
in women during this scene we see lanor
is standing next to another man who goes
by the name of Joffrey lawnmouth this is
who he's actually sexually interested in
and as I've said in other videos this
marriage will serve as an alliance
rather than an actual loving
relationship neither runnera or Lenor
will actually want to be with each other
but they know it's what's best for their
families in that new scene we even hear
renera suggests that she will still do
whatever she wants although she's now
married her father viserys watches
angrily as Damon walks off with his
daughter viserys must be nervous because
he knows what Damon really wants he
might be worried about what he might say
or what someone else might overhear
Damon saying this in the middle of her
wedding surrounded by everyone is very
risky viseris surely doesn't want this
renewed Alliance destroyed by before the
damn wedding is even over if you've seen
HBO's other official videos then you
know all hell will eventually break
loose during the ceremony this will end
up being a red wedding only not as red
as the one in Game of Thrones in HBO's
new official photos we see how most of
this episode will unfold here we see
viserys Targaryen greeting with the sea
snake in his home on drift mark this is
when visceros will offer the marriage
alliance with his daughter ranera now
since house valerion was mostly absent
in the last episode I think there will
be a major focus on their family in
these next few episodes we also get a
great shot of renera and Sir lanor
standing on the beach of driftmark this
is most likely that meeting and getting
to know each other before they
officially get married we have seen a
few shots of this scene before when
they're walking side by side while
neither one of them is actually looking
very interested in the other in these
next few photos we get several shots of
everyone during the wedding ceremony as
you can see they're holding this lavish
ceremony right in the Great Hall of the
red key you can see the Iron Throne
sitting right behind the high seats in
this shot we see viserys standing while
rhaenera and Lenor sit side by side and
once again neither one of them look
happy about being there now if you look
right next to viserys you can see the
seat is empty I think this is him
standing as his wife Allison walks into
the Great Hall in the next photo we see
her entering the hall in her green dress
now this is very interesting because
Allison is no longer wearing the black
and red of House Targaryen as you can
see now she's wearing green something
she will be known for from here on out
we have seen this in some of the other
videos as well Alison will walk into the
Great Hall then give viserys a smooch
right before sitting down at the high
table you have to wonder if she's making
a statement with the green dress I say
that because if you see Allison before
the wedding when her father is leaving
the city she is wearing the black and
redefels Targaryen now that her father
is fired his hand to the king and forced
to go back home to Old Town he gives
Alison one final farewell he reminds her
that viserys will die very soon and when
that happens she must have aegon ready
for the Iron Throne otherwise someone
else like rhaenera or even Damon will
grab it out from under her and shove her
aside Alison does look very scared in
that scene but I do wonder if she will
listen to her father will Allison
finally start setting her sights on the
Iron Throne as well maybe her getting
rid of the black and red dress for this
green one is a sign of what's to come in
the next photo we see just how sick
vasaris really is he looks rough as hell
as he's riding with his daughter ranera
now I don't know about you but raniero's
body language says a lot to me their
relationship is already fractured right
down the middle renera doesn't even
bother looking at him while viserys
looks on at his daughter not only
worried about her future but that other
Realms viserys must know she isn't ready
for what's heading her way if renera
doesn't get her [ __ ] together soon she
will lose everything now let's have a
look at HBO's new official teaser I
believe this was actually released on
Snapchat it's only a few seconds long
but it does show several new shots from
different scenes in the second half of
the season first we see a massive Dragon
surrounded by what is most likely dragon
fire now if I'm being honest I'm not
exactly sure what dragon this is it does
look black and red like Damon's Dragon
caraxis but it might also be rainey's
Dragon melees because her dragon is red
as well the dragon's face does remind me
of Damon's but it doesn't seem to have
the long neck although it is hard to say
because we're not seeing it from the
side there's still four or five more
dragons we have to see the showrunner
said we will see Nine Dragons this
season so far we've only seen four we
should be seeing vegar very soon this
new teaser gives us another glimpse of
aemon one eye as he's about the mount
vegar once he does this he will have the
oldest and largest living dragon in
Westeros and I do wonder where the hell
this dragon has been so far we've only
seen that one shot of vagar which was in
the day here we see aemon trying to
mount vegar at night I know I'm very
interested in learning more about this
dragon's whereabouts next we see a new
character wearing the long blonde hair
and armor as they're most likely
learning how to sword fight this is
obviously someone from House Targaryen I
think this might be aegon when he's a
little bit older though I'm not exactly
sure it doesn't look like either one of
the actors for aemond one eye so I think
aegon is the best bet then we see Damon
as he's walking into rhaenyra and
lenor's wedding he's wearing the same
outfit he had on during the scene while
through an era we also see a much older
Allison from later in the season then we
see viserys as he's really really sick
he's basically standing on his last leg
in this scene my guess is this is from
the episode in which he dies as you can
see he's now wearing a mask over half of
his face his sickness must be getting so
bad he's having to Shield it from
everyone else as you can imagine viserys
only has a few episodes left and once he
finally dies the dance of the Dragons
will officially begin everyone will
begin fighting over the Iron Throne just
like we saw in Game of Thrones when
Robert Baratheon died I'm very excited
and anxious to see how everything else
unfolds this season it looks like the
drama is about to be taken to a whole
new level make sure you subscribe now so
you can stay up to date on everything
Game of Thrones and House of the Dragon
I will be making five videos each week
for the remainder of the season I hope I
see all of you back here for those as
well as always I want to thank all of
you for stopping by and showing some
love on this video I'll see you again
very soon
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign